股神巴菲特说过
富利是世界上第八大奇迹
但90%的人却只搞懂了一半
就算你今天去问那些教富利的人
富利怎么运作
他们给你的答案
也会停留在
效率最慢的层级
买一档股票长期抱着
把领到的股利再拿去买股票
但这些真的是富利的全部吗?
我先给你一个数字
你自己感受一下
假设你现在手上有2万块
用这样的富利方式
每年大概是赚5%
接下来你每年都把领到的股利
全部在投入
你猜要花幾年
這兩萬塊才能變成兩億
一百九十年
對!你沒有聽錯
這已經不是你這輩子能達成的事了
這是你真真真孫那一輩
才有機會看到的數字
如果富利只有這一種玩法
那大多數人的財富自由
根本就是個假議題
但問題是
真的有人靠股票賺到第一桶金
甚至翻身致富
這些人是怎麼做到的
答案是
他們用的是更高層級的富利方法
我是小王子
在股市打滚20年
靠股票当冲跟波段
连续5年获利破千万
我先讲一个没有人愿意承认的事实
几乎所有真正靠股市赚到大把钞票的人
用的都不是刚刚那种
最低层级的复利方法
只靠股利再投入就能翻身的人
少之又少
就算真的有
也只有一种人
极致省吃俭用活到很老的长辈
他们靠的根本不是复利的威力
而是时间够长
开销够省
那其他人是怎么做到的
这就要先搞懂复利这个东西
先撇开不同的层级
多数人连最基本的名词意义都搞混了
我们先来讲什么是股利
股利就是公司赚到钱之后
分一部分的利润给股东的钱
这是公司营运的结果
跟你做了什么操作都没关系
什么是殖利率
殖利率就是
把你领到的股利
除以你买进的股价
算出来的一个百分比
可以用来衡量
这比投资相对于股价
回馈的速度有多快
很多人以为殖利率越高
就代表这档股票越好
但其实殖利率只能告诉你
配息跟股价的比例
不能告诉你总报酬
这是第一个
常常被搞混的地方
那富利到底是什么
富利的核心是
把上一轮赚到的钱
变成下一轮的本金
富利在投入
只是富利众多玩法中
速度最慢的一种
因为它一年可能只滚动一次
这就是我说的第一个层级
那第二个层级
跟第三个层级
又是什么运作的
先讲第二个层级
靠波段操作来富利
波段操作简单来说
就是不报一辈子
买进股票
只抓一段股票上涨的趋势
有可能报几天到数个月
等趋势走完
获利到位了就出场
落袋为安
为什么波段就能让复利速度变快
关键在于
鼓励复利一年零一次的鼓励
殖利率通常落在3%到5%左右
这个速度非常慢
但波段操作赚的是一整段趋势才
如果抓对方向
一次操作的报酬率可能是20% 30%
甚至更高
同样是滚一次
波段滚出来的水球会比鼓励大上好几倍
那实际上要怎么操作
波段交易看的不是公司
每年配多少股利
而是看股价的趋势和筹码的动向
筹码指的是一间公司股票的份额
一间公司在股市流通的股票
是固定的数量
当你拥有某家公司越多的股票
你就有越大的筹码
你对这家公司的股价就越有影响力
所以筹码的动向就是看股票在谁手上是在政府手上还是在某些金融机构手上那股趋势怎么看?首先要看这间公司有没有什么新闻当新闻发布后,股价有什么反应?
你能不能从股价里看出股票背后的故事?
波段交易者会在趋势刚启动
筹码开始集中的时候进场
然后抱着等股价出现转弱的迹象
再卖掉收获一整波
举个例子,假设一档股票
某一季的移收超乎大家的预期
国外的投资公司开始疯狂一直买
然后股价两个月从50块涨到65块
如果你用波段操作的方式抓到这一段
你的本金两个月就成长了30%
下个月你再拿这一笔更大的本金
重复一样的操作
这样的速度跟股息的复利完全是天差地远
这就是第二层级的复利
接下来我们要来介绍最暴力的第三层级复利
系统化当冲
当冲就是当天买进当天就卖出
股票不留隔夜
赚的是当天股价上下波动的价差
为什么当冲能让复利的速度再往上一个量级
关键已经不再是单次报酬率了
而是滚动的次数
波段交易你每年顶多交易几次到十几次
但当冲不一样
你一天可以买卖好几趟
一年下来交易次数可能是
波段的几十倍甚至几千倍
虽然当冲单次赚的幅度不大
可能只有1%到3%
但是因为滚动的次数多到极致
复利的效果会呈现爆发性的成长
假设你一天只做一次当冲
每次只赚1%
一個月就有22%
一年就有1000%
也就是說
你每過一年
本金就會多一位數
第一年2萬
第二年20萬
第三年200萬
更何況你一天做很多次
賺的可能不只1%
這跟波段和鼓勵
是完全不同量級的遊戲
但這裡要特別強調一個前提
當衝要能真正發揮負利威力
最重要的一件事
是要把交易方法系統化
也就是建立一套固定的選股邏輯
和進出場條件
讓每一筆交易都照著同一套流程走
这样你才能算出这套系统长期下来的胜率跟报酬率
如果你当冲没有系统化
明天用A方法
明天用B方法
就没办法有固定的报酬
来达到这个第三层级的复利效果
另外它还有一个其他层级都没有办法复制的优势
当冲不需要本金
就算你手上只有2万的本金
你也能操作100万的股票
你只需要付出买卖的成本和亏损的金额
这有多恐怖
我算给你听
如果你的本金就只有2万块
你去当冲一张100万的股票
赚了1%
也就是赚了1万块
实际上你这次操作
就已经赚到本金的50%了
相反的
当你亏了1%
你也会亏掉1万元
你的户头
瞬间就只剩下一半的金额了
这也是系统化的重要性
你不只是要固定流程
就连你可以玩多少钱
最多亏多少钱
都应该要制定好清楚的规则
只有在安全的系统中
你才能让当冲发挥复利的效果
但这也是为什么本金小的时候
真正的高手会选择用当冲
把复利速度做到极致
既然当充的复利速度这么快
我们如果一辈子都用当充
不就世界首富了吗
我不排除你可能是下一个世界首富
但一辈子只用当充
不会让你成为世界首富
因为这里面牵涉到一个关键问题
容量
你可能对于什么是容量
还没有什么概念
我举一个例子你就懂了
当你的本金有1亿
想当充2亿的金额
200元的股票你就要买卖1000张
今天你看到某档股票有30张
等着以202块卖出
你看涨预期会涨到210
以前你只要买10张可以直接买进都用202块买下现在呢你要买的张数实在太多了但是想以低于210元卖出的股票数量连500张都不到你如果买1000张
一定会有超过一半的数量都买贵了
换句话说
你想买的量
多到把股价推升了
这就是国中交的
供需理论
想买的很多
想卖的很少
价格就变贵了
你想赚钱
最多就只能买500张
而且这500张
没办法全部都在最好的价格买下
买的价格差
买进的张数还少
自然而然,貨率就會大打折扣
除非你選擇去當充很多人參與的股票
如果每天都有幾百億的金額在裡面做買賣
就算你買進2億,股價也不動如山
但是,這檔股票機會會比你原本選擇更好嗎?
畢竟你買進2億,股價都不會漲了
別人要買進多少億,股價才會漲到你想賺的金額
最後你會發現,原來當充能賺到的錢是有天花板的
跟你敢不敢無關,跟危不危險也無關
純粹是因為當充這場遊戲能容納的數量有限
這就是我說的容量問題
到了这个时候
你只好选择股价涨幅50% 100%的波段操作
就算你因为暴力买进1000张少赚10%
你还是有40%以上的获利
假如你的本金更大
想买的金额已经是几百亿的级别
那就要再退一步
改成长期投资去赚稳定的股利
以及几十年后股票翻好几倍的机会
这就是资金上造的巴菲特
只做长期投资背后的真相
简单来说
做得越短
负利越快
能容纳的金额也相对少
想玩的资金越大
就必须等得越久
赚得也越慢
所以结论很清楚
本金小的时候
用短线把负利速度推到极致
等本金养大
你发现短线已经容纳不下的时候
就必须转向波段交易
甚至长期投资
虽然牺牲掉负利的速度
但是至少赚到的钱
远远超过物价的上涨
负利的速度变慢
是你本金一路成长
必须经历最甜蜜的负荷
实际操作上
到底要怎么进行
这三个层级你要怎么切换
本金来到多少钱
该做哪一种成绩
我给你一个具体的阶段策略
原则很简单
能做多少是多少
假设一开始
你的本金不到200万
你可以放心的全部做当充
虽然说当充不用本金
但是如果亏损了
还是必须拿钱出来赔
我所说的系统化的当充
并不是每次都会赚钱
每次都赚这么多
而是长期来看
经过半年一年
赚了几百次
赔了几百次
发现这套流程
平均每次可以赚到这么多
所以说
就算是系统化当充
也一定会遇到亏损
你的本金必须足够支付你遇到的亏损
但你不知道你到底会遇到多少的亏损
所以一开始我建议你小金额的来尝试
每一次当冲操作的金额固定在一个区间
假设是5万块左右
也就是10元的股票当冲5张
50元的股票只当冲1张
统计1年把顺益累积起来
得到1张曲线图
如果曲线是向下的
代表这套当冲流程会太爱你赔钱
就不要再用了
如果曲线是向上的
代表这套可以用
但要特别注意
整张图表里
凹陷最多的地方
凹陷了多少钱
假设凹陷了1万块
代表你做5万的金额
最多会亏损20%
而你的本金至少要能承担
这20%的亏损
也就是说如果你本金200万
最多最多只能当充1000万的金额
因为你做1000万
亏损20%就是200万
刚好把你的本金赔光
当你的本金累积到300万
你就可以超做1500万的金额
因此类推逐步增加
那本金达到多少钱
你要改做波段交易
取决于你当充的方法不同的當衝方法能容納的金額就不一樣當你明顯感受到賺的没有以前多你当充方法被影响到了就是时候来到第二阶段了重点赶快笔记
你不需要把所有的本金全部拿去做波段
当充能做多少就做多少
假如你身上有1000万本金
你的当充方法做到满
也只需要600万的本金
你就拿剩下的400万本金去做波段交易
这才是有效率的资金分费方法
但你要记得当充跟波段是完全不同的游戏
或当初你连这档股票公司是做什么的都不需要知道
但做波段你要了解的比较多
最近有什么财经新闻
对哪些股票会有影响
股票的筹码掌握在谁手上
目前的股价还有没有上涨空间
这些都是你能不能赚到第二层级负利的关键
那什么时候要转换到第三层级的负利
这里我得先讲清楚一件事
就像前面所说的
一档股票筹码都是固定的量
当你想买的数量多到一定的程度
你就可以左右股价的走势
这时候我们就可以称你为这档股票的主力
这时你需要学的是另外一个技术
如何在不影响股价的情况买进够多的股票
如何诱使那些跟进买进的人
把股票低价卖给你
如何让更多人用更贵的价格买进你的股票
所以什么时候要用第一层级的复利
取决于你是否学会这些技术
它们可以让波段交易的容量达到另一个级别
但事实上不学也可以
等你走到这一步
你的本金已经足够让你实现你理想的生活
真正让你提早使用长期投资的原因
不是因为你想投资的量级太大
也不是因为你学不会那些
主力该学会的技术
反而是因为你手上钱多了
你害怕失去它
决定分配一部分去做相对安全的投资
以免你一路走来的薰雪
哪一天全部消失不见
毕竟你已经不需要赚得很快了
你需要的是赚得很安全
牺牲一些高层级的富力
反而能够让你更踏实
更没有负担
我们把三个阶段串起来看
从2万块到几百亿
绝对不可能一招就打遍天下
你需要随着本金的规模换不同的工具
去匹配当下最适合的滚动速度
这才是一个普通人
真正能让本金快速成长
在此生达到财富自由最可能的路径
用讲的都很容易
做起来处处都是困难
最可能主案你达到财富自由的原因有两个
第一缺乏风险意识
90%投资人要么太充
都不好好控制亏损的金额
要么太说
因为害怕亏损
该做的不敢做
但真正的风险意识
是你控制好亏损
该做就做
该赚就赚 该赔就赔
用系统化的操作
指导资金安全的成长
第二 试错成本不足
要找到一套适合你
又真正有效的系统
需要花大把的时间
大把的钞票
来重复测试和统计
我们这样没什么时间
本金还少少了普通人
到底应该用什么方式
来建议自己的投资系统
我的建议是
直接抄别人的系统吧
有很高的几率
你能够参考它的系统
建议你自己的系统
不要像我一样
傻傻的摸索十几年
才建立起二三层级的复利系统
开始滚动本金
我不建议你直接超过去用
不要浪费你宝贵的时光
我都已经把他们整理成
七大当充获利数
和波段买卖的价位设计法
全部放在我的线上讲座里
里面除了系统之外
我还会分享两种
找到标滚的方法
赶快到资讯栏点击连结就能免费报名
讲座的名额有限
如果点连结进去
没有看到直播尝试代表额满了
看完这部影片
你对赚钱的认知
應該已經提升到輕易的維度了
但認知在還沒開始行動前
都只是在腦子裡
只有透過實踐才能真正走向你認知中的財富自由
我是小王子
我們下次見